gus plans to install a handrail around a
skating rink
the rink forms a 40 meter by 20 meter
rectangle
how many meters of handrail does gus
need
so here's what we know about this
skating rink
it's a 40 meter
by 20 meter rectangle so let's draw the
skating rink that might help us
to visualize
and we know
that one side length is 40 meters
and another side length is 20 meters
so gus definitely needs to put some
handrails 40 meters here and 20 meters
here but that is not enough as somebody
who doesn't know how to skate i very
much hope gus puts handrail on this
length and this length also
he needs to put the handrails all the
way around the outside or what we could
call the perimeter of the shape the
entire distance around the outside
because this skating rink is a rectangle
we know that opposite sides are equal so
if this length is 40 meters up here then
this length down here must also be 40
meters
and we can do the same thing with 20 if
we have 20 over here
then the length across must also be 20
meters
so now we can figure out the entire
amount of handrail gus needs the amount
of meters he needs to buy to put around
the skating rink
for this first side here he needs 40
meters
plus to go down this side he'll need
another 20 meters of handrail
going across the bottom of the rink
he'll need another 40 meters of handrail
and then going up the side he'll need
another
20 meters of handrail
so we can add these to find the total
amount he needs 40 plus 20 is 60
then
60 plus 40
plus 40 is a hundred
and 100 plus 20 more is 120
meters
so to go the entire distance around the
outside of the skating rink or the
perimeter of the skating rink with
handrail gus will need 120
meters of handrail